I mean what do you want to know my name
is Maya Z the inventor of the selfie
perhaps the perfectionist of the selfie
definitely
I am the name behind many of the most
famous selfies you've seen the great
Ellen photograph of the Oscars many of
Kim Kardashian's you look closely you
can see me in the background directing
it as if it were an orchestra that's why
I'm here she's the best yeah I've always
wanted to be popular and I know that to
be popular it starts with Instagram
I followed her work with the iPhone 4 4
s oh let's not forget about the 5 and 5s
how does it smell in here like a good
selfie my motto is no your selfie what
does the background the lighting the
angle what does it say about you my
friend Joshua took a picture with like
just his six-pack and you got like 500
likes in 52 minutes and he changed his
name to Viper I just kind of want what
Viper has my background is in online
dating selfies you know the lowest form
of selfie and I just asked myself what
else is there can you preview tafoya
thank you but you're in it so say you
see a rabbit and you want to catch that
rabbit you are the rabbit you are the
trap you want to eat yourself for dinner
that and if nothing else is truly the
definition of what it is to capture
yourself I was a busboy at Joe's Crab
Shack for two years saving up so I could
have this experience with my I see I'm
very intimidated to be working with Maya
today but I'm also excited on a good day
we walk out of the studio with some
amazing selfies and on a bad day I'll
have to clean up a lot of broken
iPhone 6s and no I will not disclose
which filters I may or may not use I
enjoy Siena my cousin not the filter so
how tall is she yes don't worry we'll
use one of mine four inches up one
centimeter down up lower how can you
like me with how many likes only 25 25
right looking to the screener into the
camera so go back to the happy place
the date is July 4th Independence Day a
film starring Will Smith you went to see
it when it came up
you bought a popcorn with large butter
you met a girl named Brenda and you're
kissed are at that theater take your
selfie paint shootin welcome thank you
hi will be $5,000 when a photo is taken
of you Renard piece of your soul is
taken but when you take a selfie you
gain that piece of your soul back John
Lennon do I know what this is
a back scratcher I think it's a what is
this a joke
this being sold to children how would
you feel if a man with no arms saw you
use a selfie stick how do you think he'd
feel here's my selfie stick and here's
my other one